[Music]
Jordan it is wonderful to be here with
you today so great to be here with you
this so excited so let's start I want to
hear about your background how did you
get into Theater Broadway and
entertainment yes I it all saided when I
was really young like about six years
old um I would always put on these plays
in my living room and I would cut up my
mom's weave and my dad's work uniform
and make costumes I don't know why they
didn't beat my mind but I I really just
like love tell stories and love becoming
other characters and and making my
cousin be characters of other like I I
just had this kind of Storytelling bug
inside of me that I couldn't help but
get out um and so that started with like
me doing plays in the living room to
going to the backyard to Growing from
the backyard to doing them in the church
um then when they got a little bit too
much for the church then I got a credit
card and I started maxing them out and
putting putting up like plays in like
rec centers and and gyms and art art
culture centers things like that um I
just I just had to get these stories out
of me and these characters out of me and
I I loved interacting with audiences and
so that just grew and then when I moved
to New York I would like hand out flyers
in Time Square and like on the subway
trying to like pass out and let people
know that my shows were happening and
that just grew and grew and then I uh
was went to college at the new school
then I did uh ain't noo at the public
theater and then it went from the public
theater to Broadway and how did you
convince producers to to take a chance
on you and take a chance on ain't no mo
and get it to Broadway yeah you know
what's crazy is I really had to do a lot
of the work myself first really yeah
because it was one of those pieces where
it just wasn't like anything else you
know when people want you to compare
something to something it's like I don't
really know what it's comparative to um
but really I had to believe in myself
and believe in my work before I trusted
other people to believe in it for me
right and I think that started with
putting on readings like with the
community like finding different
different organizations that would let
me just set up music stands and call
friends and read a play right and I
think once I started doing that that's
when um Jack Phils Moore from the public
theater ended up seeing uh a reading of
it that was done in New York Theater
Workshop was TV Walker web and it just
kind of grew from there but it all
started with you know doing it for
myself because nobody people told me it
wasn't a play literally I remember
sending it to certain theaters and and
they'll be like we don't know what this
is but it's not a play they're like what
how does this work on stage you know now
for the non Broadway informed like us
can you please explain um the synopsis
of your play yes so an noo is basically
about if all black people in America got
a email saying that they had to go back
to Africa and you watch all these
different people around the country
decide whether or not they're getting on
the final plane out of America there's
only one plane left and all these people
are deciding whether or not they're
getting on it yeah and I think the
important part is you also starred in it
I did what tell me about why you made
that decision yeah so I I started it as
Peaches who's who's the drag queen
flight attendant who gets all these
millions of black folks on this plane um
you know what's funny about it is that
my spirit knew I was writing that role
for myself but my ego didn't because I
was a little afraid to step into it and
I wrote it for other actors specifically
and nobody really could get the music
the way that I wanted the music to go
right and finally you know our our
director was just like you need to do it
and I was like I don't know we we
literally had to let go of an actor um
hours before a performance um because it
just wasn't working and I was like what
are we gonna do and he was like Jordan
you're an actor you and you know this
script better than anybody you know this
character so I just put on that wig and
I went out there and I and I got all
those people on that plane that amazing
and and it and it just stuck and it fit
like a glove I didn't even realize I was
fighting it for so long and then finally
when I did it I was like wow this this
actually is is is me yeah and you made
history as the youngest black playright
in Broadway history which is incredible
how did that make you feel insane you
know insane like it's something you
don't even really think about you know
because you're too busy just doing the
work but to think about the fact that
you know the person before me was
Lorraine hansbury wrote a raising in the
sun in 1958 you know so the think that
I'm like following in that in that
Footsteps in that lineage is just
excites me and also you know to me is
the beginning of the future it's the
beginning of a new kind of Storytelling
and a new kind of theater A New Kind of
Broadway you know definitely now talk to
me about the day you received your Tony
nomination because that's huge what were
you feeling and then talk to me about
the the awards process and sitting there
too wow like I was what's so funny is I
it just so so happened to coincide with
me going back home so I was back home in
Texas okay the day that we got the
nominations and it was so
surreal because we were watching the
news and hearing my name come across
that many times in the same living room
where I used to do those plays and I
just feel like there's a there's a
there's a version of me there's a little
Jordan version of me that is just still
jumping around somewhere just can't
cannot believe how far I've come from
doing living room plays to being on
Broadway and then to getting six Tony
nominations like what that's crazy that
is crazy um and one of the things I know
we've talked about this before is when
you were you know putting out aomo you
asked on social media you said um you
asked if Broadway was ready for it yeah
do you feel this way post production do
you feel Broadway was ready for it and
then you know looking at what you're
doing now in Hollywood do you think the
world is ready for for things like that
yeah I don't think so I think I think
that you know no one's ever ready for
anything I really do believe that as
humans we just learn to get ready we
learn to be prepared um in a way that
like with anything whether it's art
whether it's legislation you know a lot
of people didn't just you know say oh
now we're gonna eradicate Jim Crow right
it's like no you were forced to
eradicate Jim Crow right and I think
that when it comes to Art it's that
exact same kind of thing I always say
that the kind of art that I want to make
I don't want to make the art that people
want today I want to make the art that
they need tomorrow you know and I think
that that is Ain no mo in capsulated and
all of my work encapsulated even with
you know the Miss Pat show like that was
something that you know people told me I
was crazy to make and that it wouldn't
work and that's not how TV works and you
can't you know break magical realism and
do all these things and then it ends up
you know being the first thing to ever
get uh the network iny nominations you
know in 40 years of existence over 40
years so it's that thing of like you
know when people aren't ready that's
when you know you're supposed to do it
yeah because otherwise we would always
stay stagnant you know no that's a great
way of looking at it yeah how did the
success that you had on Broadway into
the theater Community then translate
into success in in Hollywood and did you
learn any business lessons from one that
you carry to the other absolutely there
was a I was talking with somebody about
this earlier this idea of fearlessness
you know and I think my fearlessness
came
from adversity always pushing back
against adversity I always tell this
story about the the first time that uh I
went to high school and know knew that
there were there was a theater class
because in junior high I created the
drama club because I was just a theater
geek um but when I got to high school I
was like yo like there's going to be a
class and it's gonna be lit and I don't
got to do nothing I can just show up you
know and so I get there and it's me and
this other girl sarapo we're the only
two black people in the entire the
department and we were all wanting to
audition for this fall play so we
auditioned for the fall play play and
then afterwards the teacher pulls us
aside and she says Jordan you know
you're so great you're so great but
you're just not right for this show
you're just not right for this part then
pull saraphina apart saraphina you're so
great you're so great but you know I
can't give you this part because you
would have to be romantic with a white
boy on stage and would look like peanut
butter and tuna on stage together like
the most rid that's the that's the
verbatim quote like ridiculous but I
remember being so upset by that that I
couldn't do anything but right and I to
play for a saraphina and myself and I
got the prettiest white boy in school to
play her husband and we made like $700
off of $2 tickets in a weekend and uh a
local theater company DVA Productions
ended up coming and seeing that play and
they ended up producing it because they
liked it so much and that was my first
professionally produced play at 16 years
old but there was this constant idea of
of adversity right of pushing back and
finding ways to go against the grain so
so with that there's also the aspect of
foolishness I believe everybody should
have an ounce of foolishness in them
because
fools are brave because they don't know
any better right and there's a stagnant
fool which no one wants to be and
there's an active fool which we should
all want to be an active fool is is
fearless and an active fool pushes
forward and because they're foolish
their people around them are like you
can't do that you can't do that that's
not how we've done that we've never done
that before right but you're just moving
Carefree through onto what you believe
is right right and I kind of have taking
that from theater and then also bringing
it to my like television and film aspect
of myself which one is always going to
have a theatrical element to it just
because theater is my heart and I feel
like everything should be theatrical I
feel like to be honest I feel like a lot
of film and television takes away our
imagination because it presents us
everything instead of asking us to come
towards it right and I think that that
when it came to
television I just was a TV geek so I
knew I knew a lot about a lot so
specifically uh with my show it's a
sitcom in front of a live audience right
so I love Desi arnes and Luc B Desi Ares
literally created what we know to be the
television sitcom now right but bet had
never done a traditional sitcom before
they were used to like laugh tracks
right they were used to a certain kind
of sitcom that shoots an episode a day
and that you know not the old school and
I wanted to do that old school kind of
thing right but there were people in the
along the way who were like we we can't
do that we don't do that a audience
right how you GNA do two shows in a day
and shoot it how you gonna do rehearse
from Monday through Wednesday and I'm
like no but I know these people did it
in 1951 so why can't we do it in 2023
you know and you know they ended up
trusting me in a lot of things not only
in the in the format but also the
content you know they were like you
can't say that we can't say that but it
it all came from my bravery of being a a
a Forward Thinking fool yeah you know
interesting and how were you able to
like break into the Hollywood scene
convince bet to take a chance on you how
what was that process like for you oh
that was a journey so so the Miss Pat
show specifically started at um I was I
was 23 when I wrote it and I actually
wrote it in my apartment I y'all I used
to live in this in this horrible New
York apartment I didn't have a closet I
slept on a futon I always said I had
five roommates and two rats cuz it was
just the best um but I wrote that pilot
and I knew that I wanted to do a old
school sitcom but I wanted it to be
R-rated I wanted to be uncensored I
wanted you know this this black family
to talk how like a lot of a lot of
parents talk you know around their kids
you know and so I wanted to put that on
air and kind of specifically with Miss
Pat who's I don't know if you know who
she is but she's like she's an amazing
comedian she she lived a crazy life she
had two kids by the time she was 15 been
shot twice sold drugs went to prison and
now she's a stand up comedian and so
basically I wanted to create this sitcom
around her in the same vein of like red
fox or Bernie Mack or Richard prior but
with them they weren't allowed to really
be themselves in a lot of ways because
television wasn't ready for that and so
I wanted to try something new and give a
comedian who's used to like going on
stage and you know being themselves the
ability to be themselves in front of a
live studio audience in a sitcom family
said right and so I tried to do this and
they were like no no no it'll never work
so I remember Miss Pat um because Fox we
were at Fox at the time and fox said you
know um Lee Daniels brought brought me
to Fox and Miss Pat brought me to Fox
and they were like absolutely not we're
not giving a kid in college a television
show I don't care how good his plays are
they were like we we're not we're not
doing that right so Lee's like you know
well we're going to keep trying and Miss
Pat calls me and she's she's not from
the Hollywood scene either so she does
things a certain way so she calls me and
she's like yo they're not going to give
you this job they don't want you to make
this show um and she said but I want you
to do something for me I want you to
write the first episode I was like what
she was like write the first episode and
take your name off of it I was like what
do you mean take my name off of it wow
so I took my name off of it I wrote the
episode
trusting and she sent it in to Fox her
and Lee Daniels and fox said who wrote
this and they said it was the kids you
didn't want to
hire what a good strategy yeah and
that's how I ended up like being able to
T have my own show yeah that's really
cool yeah now the thing that's unique
about you is you've been like you know
Talent you've been forward facing and
then you've also been behind the scenes
you've been a writer obviously what's it
been like managing yourself as like the
the Jordan Cooper brand no it's been
it's been really interesting you know
because there's there's multiple sides
of me there are people who know me more
for my acting or being on pose or you
know uh the idea of me you know getting
getting nominations as an actor on
Broadway and then there are the people
you know who are used to me just being
behind the camera and directing episodes
and and showrunning and putting out
fires that's really what showrunning is
you you're constantly walking around
with a fire hose putting out fires
constantly getting phone calls at 5
o'clock in the morning saying this actor
wants to wear this wig or or we got to
repain this set this color we need your
approval on this it's it's constantly
you know getting your hands dirty you
know people swear the people I work with
on my set you know they get so surprised
when I'm actually like working and doing
events because they're like oh you
really clean up nice and I'm like you're
just used to me seeing me with a fire
hose that's why you know and but they
they really work on both sides of my
brand because there's a side of me that
is yes I am in front of the camera yes I
am you know the actor but also I have to
make sure that that the things are being
cooked in the kitchen you know um and
both of those things kind of work for
the same me one one one hand and the
other that that is cool so going along
with that because now I think we can
consider you also a business person yeah
is there one business rule that you've
learned along the way that you operate
by no matter what o Listen to
Everybody listen to everybody because
there you you'll never you'll NE you can
never
underestimate how your employees will
work harder for you when you respect
them as human beings there's something I
always say this especially like being on
television and comedy you know I'm I'm
the person in charge you know I'm I'm in
I'm the one telling everybody where to
go and doing all the things but I'm also
not afraid to be
wrong so I would say if there's a
custodian who's sweeping the floor and
he has a better joke than the one I just
put in this that joke is going to go in
there you know I'm never there is no
respected person so that's that's one
also scare money don't make money you
know scare scare money don't make money
so you can't you can't move fearly you
can't move fearful in all that you do
you can't move looking at how this
person did or how that person did it and
maybe I shouldn't do that because that
person didn't do it that way no you have
to move that's where you get the bank
from that's where you get the audience
from that's where you get the money from
is this idea of being Fearless because
through fearlessness you get that bold
product absolutely yeah how do you
maintain being yourself versus you know
the public that you showed everyone else
in the world yeah that's an interesting
question I'm out my
business no sure for real I after every
night after doing eight Broadway is
eight shows a week I would go on that
stage I would do eight shows a week I
would go outside I would sign the
autographs take the pictures then when I
went home I baked cookies and watched
divorce court that is that is that was
my guilty pleasure trash television and
cookies that but but it did something to
like really just help me stay grounded
and help me stay safe and also your
circle is important you know everybody
can't go with you you know that leads
into my next question perfectly which is
like how do you find the right mentors
both in in Hollywood and in theater and
who have those people been for you yeah
you know what wild is that I'm so
grateful that in every phase of my life
I've had mentors that not only that I I
admire but have helped push me along the
way just just through advice yeah right
and like specifically like it started
with my Sunday school teacher cuz she
was the only one once again I was I was
grew up in Texas so it's football so
nobody's really like let's go to the
theater you know what I mean but my
Sunday school teacher Miss Peggy she she
still has my first play that I wrote
when that she says I was like four she
still has it and she takes it everywhere
whenever we see each other but she
really poured into me because she
understood you know theater she might
not have been you know what I mean but
she understood it so it went from her to
like Shan gby Keon to Yaki Smith um to
to to all these people then when I got
like to Hollywood the people who I
considered to be my like Mount Everest
of entertainment literally became my
mentors from Debbie Allen to to Norman
Lear who like literally is the blueprint
of of my work in television um to Tyler
Perry to Lee Daniels to to to to who
else like I can't even I can cleanand t
all these people who
who validated my existence in my want
and my art even when I was just a kid
doing it in the living room now can look
at me and say you're good kid you know I
love that that that's that's so
validating like after Norman Lear saw
the pilot of the Miss Pat show and he
sent me a video saying how much he loved
the pilot and how great he was to me
like I was like what you know all of the
family good times and and like it's just
it's just so humbling and what I find so
beautiful is that those people teach me
how to move forward with my baton you
know when it's my turn to you know
continue moving forward how to look back
and and make sure that you're actually
grooming and uplifting and inspiring
those who are coming behind you you know
absolutely I've just taken that with me
and it means so much and like the fact I
always say that Michael Jackson quote is
one of my favorite codes study the
greats and become even greater I love
that yeah that's great advice you have a
dream collaborator and and who would it
be in why oh I have so many Beyonce yes
I think she's all of our Dream
collaborator list Listen Beyonce I'm G
Listen Beyonce I think she's I think
she's such a great actress and I think
that it's hard to escape the like
Supernova of like you know people seeing
Beyonce and everything you do um but I
think she she's super super super just
talented and a hard worker and I would
love to work with her also Val Davis
also Angela Basset also like like who
else there's so many like dope Florence
Pew is really dope too I would love
watching her um there's so many actors
and actresses that I I just cannot wait
to to work with um Stephen seim is like
one of my
biggest yes he's one of my biggest
Inspirations as far as literature
because he's a playwright even though
he's a composer he writes plays and his
songs um and I remember one time he
inspires me to write for women too
because the the the way that he wrote
for women is just unparalleled musically
um especially in that time period too
what like ridiculous and I think that
that's and I was raised around a lot of
strong women so I feel like that's why
you know the first when I sit down to
write a character the first mouth that
opens is usually the the voice of a
woman um I love that so it's so
interesting but also um like Stephen
seim oh I gotta tell you the story okay
so Stephen seim I was in the public
theater and I was workshopping a noo at
the time and I had my backpack you know
I I'm I'm just college student I'm
running from class and I go downstairs
and I see Stephen son it took me like
five minutes to go up to him because I
was like is that Ste Sten son and I went
up to him and I was just like Stephen oh
my gosh like you're you're you're
amazing like your work has made my life
he was like really I was like yeah yeah
yeah your work your work has made my
life he was like is your life
good and I said yeah yeah I think so he
said then that's a damn good compliment
a and I just hold that moment with me so
like uh just we have so many Legends who
are just constantly spitting out gyms um
in their mouths and also in their work
and I'm I'm just so grateful to have
them and I can't wait to collaborate
with with them and absolutely future
generations and I'm sure you've got a
lot of rejection in your career being in
theater being in Hollywood tell me about
that experience for you and any advice
you have for others who maybe pitching
or going through similar rejections in
their fields yeah you know rejection I
know it's corny to say but I always I
always believe that old ad that old
adage is rejection is protection in a
lot of ways
because sometimes you have this really
bold this really beautiful part of
yourself that is not yet ready to be in
the hands of just anybody right and I
say that because sometimes we have to
train people how to receive us and we
have to train people how to receive our
work and the way that we train them is
really to believe in our first and
invest in our first and don't wait for
anybody to open the door for you or give
you the green light you are the traffic
light you can switch it to Green when
you want to switch it to green and
switch it to red when you want to switch
it to red and really just believing in
yourself don't let nobody talk you out
of what you know to be true right
because if they can't give you the space
you can find the space if you got to do
it in the living room if you got to do
it in the backyard if you got to do it
at the rec center do it right crowdfund
find ways or do that N9 to-5 do what you
got to do save up a dollar $10 every
week $20 every week so by the end of the
year you can rent out of space you know
really just pour into yourself because
in every aspect of my life you know I've
just there's always some form of you're
not good enough there's always some form
of we don't get it we don't understand
it that's too much that's tooo you know
and when I come to those Crossroad
I realized that every time feels like
the first time I've heard no you know it
feels like the first time that
somebody's told me no and I think that
what I'm grateful for is because I've
received so many NOS at some point
Spirit just knocked something into my
head it's like do you know who you are
do you know what you've done when people
told you you couldn't do it when people
said it was
impossible what you are is a path maker
is a way maker and I believe all of us
are way makers all of us have something
within us that that is built to to lay a
path that has not never existed before
right and of course people are going to
say you can't lay a path there if
they've never seen one so you have to
start laying the brick and if you start
laying that brick so eloquently and so
beautifully and so perfectly other
people are like that's a nice that looks
like fun I need to lay a brick down let
me help you out you know what I mean let
me let that Breck down before you know
you got a highway you got a highway
where you want to go and I think that
that's what's really you know pushed me
forward is to never ever ever take no
for an answer when there's a yes in the
bottom of your gut that's great advice
yeah what's next for you what are you
targeting the future any goals hopes
dreams that you want to have yeah you
know I want to continue to grow my
company the and cookout entertainment I
want to continue to make television and
film and I also want to help you know
really bridge that gap of theater to
being a lot more accessible and a lot
more um welcoming to to people who may
not be able to afford to get to the
theater or afford to a flight to New
York to get to Broadway or even a gas to
drive to Manhattan you know I want to to
really make my work accessible uh and
help uplift and amplify voices that are
so often silenced yeah and finally
Jordan what would you want your legacy
to
be inspiration I want to inspire people
to live to laugh to love to cry to heal
to dance to twerk to cook to love I want
to inspire people I want to inspire
generations to do those things um
through my work you know and through my
existence as a person and also also I
just want to be known for leaving doors
wide open you know so it doesn't have to
be as hard for somebody else you know
there's Footprints there's a pathway
there's a door stop because because I
heard a no maybe it's that much easier
for somebody to hear yes because I push
through that now you know that's
excellent thank you so much Jordan that
is incredible advice and it has been a
pleasure chatting with you today thank
you so much for joining me thank you
thank you so glad to be
here